christina says david sorry if i missed
the reason but why was hatred mail
removed from your show oh okay this is
interesting yeah if
if peop i'll tell the story now and if
people want to clip this then maybe
we'll re-upload it
as a we'll re-upload it as a clip
so basically because because of what
happened with the election
and the amount of violence real and
threatened that's been going on
as many of you know we get threats all
the time and they're forwarded to
authorities we've had
fbi agents have actually shown up at the
houses of people who have who have sent
threats um and there's many stories
i could tell maybe 20 years from now i
will tell them
the long and short of it is a bunch of
people including federal authorities
said that the hatred mail segment is
probably creating
sort of like false positives
and and making it hard creating more
noise around the signal
and they felt strongly that
um it's probably it probably should be
suspended because
situa trumpets are so violent and
so volatile and then january 6th
happened
so basically that's it we very quietly
just stopped doing hatred mail like i
didn't do an announcement the the
recommendation from
um security consultants and fbi
was probably probably cut it for the
time being things are just too volatile
um so uh that's that's the reason
that's the reason i don't know i need to
say unceremoniously yeah
and obviously i was in touch with um
hatred male guy
and you know maybe it'll come back is he
still getting paid it was a volunteer
thing you know the funniest thing hatred
mail guy is a professional voiceover
artist one of the funniest things he
would write to me
about hatred mail is i've done
voice-over for
movies tv shows commercials this is him
speaking
the the only thing my wife thinks i do
that's cool is hatred mail hatred mail
guy's wife
is a big fan and she was uh loving
hatred mail
but that's the story that's the story